Most Traits have a distribution in a population, or
they exist on a Spectrum. This is what we would
call a Normal Distribution or a Bell Curve, looking
at the shape. It looks like a dome-shaped bell. Let's
imagine that this the Risk distribution curve for Breast
Cancer in a population of women. What this means is
that we took a population of women, let's say in
the United States or elsewhere. And we tally each individual's
risk for breast cancer. And then after tallying everything
up we put it in this graph here. On
the horizontal, or X axis, we have the risk
of breast cancer, which is measured as a probability
or a percent. And the vertical axis, or the
Y axis here, shows how many women have that
particular risk. For example, in this particular normal distribution,
the most number of women have a breast cancer risk
of about 12%. You can see the height of
the bell curve is here. About 30% of women
have a 12% risk of breast cancer. This number
right in the middle, the average, this means that 12%
of women develop breast cancer during their lifetime. Another
way to say this, is that the average woman has
about a 12% risk for developing breast cancer. This
is how we can turn population data into a risk
assessment for an individual person. As the bell curve
indicates, most women's risks will be close to the average
of 12%. And as you get farther away from
the middle, fewer and fewer will have an average risk.
The women down here will have a lower risk
of developing breast cancer. And the women over here will
have a higher risk of developing breast cancer. But
as you can see, most women fall into the category
near the average risk.